hey i'm kim coates Elliot and I work on
humanities content at Khan Academy so I
thought about things that were really
difficult for me and one thing that was
hard for me was class discussion because
I went to this history class and I swear
that every other person in that class
had like read every history book ever
and I don't know how they did it but I
was convinced that I was an imposter I
did not belong in this class everyone
else was just completely brilliant and
you know they would they would sit
around and discuss these ideas and they
were kind of vicious you know say like
oh you know this textbook is wrong this
person had a has a terrible argument and
I'd be sitting there thinking I haven't
they wrote a textbook like that's a
pretty big deal um so I was just I think
I was just terrified to open my mouth in
this class and kind of like reveal to
everyone that I didn't belong there and
so I went to a teacher who was a mentor
to me and I said everybody's so mean I'm
just I'm not this mean and he said to me
you know it's okay to be the person who
says what can we learn from this and
it's okay to be the person who wants to
take something positive away from this
class